i recently read about what the young
generation of workers
won in harvard business review one thing
that stuck out to me was
don't just talk about impact but
make an impact i'm a little bit older
than you
much older than you but this is the
exact
same goal that i had when i was in
college
i wanted to make my own impact for those
who live under injustice
the reason that i became a documentary
journalist
the reason i became the prisoner
in north korea for 140 days
it was march 17 2009
it is saint patrick's day for all of you
but it was the day
that turned my life upside down
my team and i were making a documentary
about north korean
refugees living below human life
in china we were
at the border it was our last day of
filming
there's no wire fence or bars
or sign to show that it is the border
but this is a place where a lot of north
korean defectors use as an escape route
it was still winter and the river was
frozen
when we were in the middle of the river
on the frozen river
we're filming about the condition of the
cold weather
and the environment the north koreans
had to deal with
when they seek for freedom and suddenly
one of my team members shouted
soldiers so i looked back
and there were two small soldiers in
green uniform with rifles chasing after
us we all ran as fast as we could
i pray that please don't let them shoot
my head
and i was thinking that if my feet are
on chinese soil i'll be safe and
i made it to chinese soil then
i saw my colleague laura lynn fell on
her knees
i didn't know what to do at that short
moment but i
knew that i could not leave her alone
there when she said
you know i can feel my legs
a flash we were surrounded by these two
korean soldiers
they were not much bigger than us but
they were determined to take us
to their army base i begged and
yelled for any kind of health hoping
that someone would show up from china
here i was being stubborn towards
a trained soldier with a gun i looked at
his eyes
he was just a boy at the moment he
raised his rifle to hit me
but i saw that he was hesitating his
eyes were shaken
and his rifle was still in up in the air
so i shouted at him okay okay
i'll walk with you and i got up
when we arrived at their army base
my head was spinning with these worst
case scenarios
and my colleague statement wasn't
helping she said
we are the enemy she was right
we were the enemy and i was supposed to
be frightened too
but i kept having these odd experiences
this time
on office around his coat to keep me
warm
he's because i lost my coat on the
frozen river while battling with this
one of soldiers
i will tell you what i mean by this odd
experience
i grew up in south korea to us
north korea was always the enemy even
before i was born
south and north have been under
armistice for
63 years since end of the korean war
and grow in south in the 80s and 90s
we are top propaganda about north korea
and we heard so many graphic stories
such as a little young boy
being brutally killed by north korean
spies because
he just said i don't like communists
or i watched this cartoon series
about young south korean boy defeating
this fat
big red pig which represented the north
koreans first leader at the time
and effect of hearing this horrible
stories over and over
instilled one word in a young mind
enemy and i think at some point i
dehumanized them
and the people of north korea
became equated with the north korean
government
now back to my detention it was
second day of being in a cell
i had not slept since i was out at the
border
this young guard came to my cell
and offered me this s'more boiled egg
and said this will give you strength to
keep going
do you know what it is like receiving a
small kindness
in enemy's hands whenever they were kind
to me
i thought the worst case was waiting for
me after the kindness
and one officer noticed my nervousness
said did you think we were all these red
pigs
referring the cartoon that i just showed
you
every day was like a psychological
battle
the interrogator had me sit at a table
six days a week and had me writing down
about my journey my work over and over
until
i wrote down the confession that they
wanted here
about three months of detention
the north korea korean court sentenced
me to 12 years in a labor camp
so i was just sitting in my room to be
transferred
at the time i really have nothing else
to do so i paid attention to these two
female guards
and listening on what they were talking
about
guard a was older and she studied
english she seemed like she came from an
affluent
family she often showed up with this
color for dresses and then loved to show
off
and guard b was younger one
and she was a really good singer she
loved to sing this indians my heart will
go on
sometimes too much he just knew
how to torture me without knowing
and this girl spent a lot of time
in the morning to put on makeup
like you can see in any young girl's
life
and they love to watch this chinese
drama
a better quality production and i
remember
guard b said i can no longer watch our
tv shows
after watching this she got scored
for degrading her own country's produced
tv show
guard b had more of a free mind than
guard a
and she got often escorted by guard a
whenever she expressed herself one day
they invited all these
female colleagues i don't know where
they came from
to where i was helped and they invited
me to their guards room and asked
if one night stands really happened in
the u.s
this is the country where
young couples are not even allowed
toward hands in public
i had no idea where they got this
information but they were shy
and giggling even before i said anything
we i think we all forgot that i was
their prisoner
and it was like going back to my high
school classroom again
and i learned that these girls also grew
up watching
a similar cartoon but just
propaganda towards south korea and the
us
i certainly don't understand where these
people's anger
was coming from if these girls grew up
learning that we
are enemies it was just natural that
they would hate us
just as i fear them
but at the moment we were just old girls
who shared the same interest
beyond our ideologies that separated us
i shared these stories with my boss at
current tv
at the time after i came home his first
reaction was
you know have you heard stockholm
syndrome
yes and i clearly remember
the feeling of fear and being threatened
and tension rising up between me and the
interrogator when we talked about
politics
there definitely was a wall that we
couldn't climb over
but we were able to see each other as
human beings
when we talked about family everyday
life
the importance of a future of our
children
it was about a month before i came home
i got
really sick guard b
stopped by my room to say goodbye
because
she was leaving the detention center
she made sure that no one watched us no
one hears us
and quietly said i hope you get better
and go back to your family soon
it is these people the officer
who brought me his coat the guard who
offered me
a boiled egg these female
guards who asked me about dating life in
the u.s
they are the ones that i remember of the
north korea
humans just like us
north koreans and i were not ambassador
of
our countries but i believe that we were
representing
the human race
now i'm back home back to my life
the memory of these people has blurred
as time has passed
and i'm in this place where i read and
hear about north korea provoking the u.s
i realized how easy it is
to see them as an enemy again
but i have to keep reminding myself that
when i was over there
i was able to see humanity over hatred
in my enemy's eyes
thank you